une fin d'année sombre et difficile
voilà comment vous le dit mieux Zelenski
voilà période en Ukraine face au
pressing constant qu'exerce l'armée
russe dans le bon basse notamment la
situation sur le front exige toute la
force et la concentration de la nation
ukrainienne estime le chef de l'État à
Kiev ou les s'exprimait hier on
s'inquiète aussi des effets sur les
Ukrainiens des coupures de courant à
répétition et les neuvolochine vous qui
êtes sur place pour France 24
électricité reste un enjeu pour nombre
du crédit
oui bien sûr parce que quand vous n'avez
pas d'électricité vous n'avez pas non
plus d'eau vous n'avez pas de chauffage
alors les températures sont négatives
ici en Ukraine cela étant dit vous
pouvez voir sans doute derrière moi en
ce moment Kiev la capitale a retrouvé
quelques lumières je vous parlais il y a
quelques jours depuis ce balcon et la
ville était totalement plongée dans le
noir quasiment les électriciens ont pu
travailler les compagnies d'électricité
pour rétablir le courant dans la
majorité des quartiers avec toujours des
coupures de rationnement à mes enfants
la situation c'est quand même améliorer
tout simplement parce que cela fait une
dizaine de jours maintenant que
l'infrastructure énergétique de la
capitale n'a pas été la cible des
frappes longue portée qui avait
débranché le courant ceci étant dit la
situation reste quand même très
compliquée vous le mentionniez 9
millions d'ukrainien privé d'électricité
en cet hiver il y a Kiev il y a d'autres
grandes villes il y a aussi les zones
rurales nous étions par exemple hier
dans la région de kerkiff où
l'infrastructure et les habitations sont
totalement dévastées pour pour certains
villages les combats par plusieurs mois
de feux d'artillerie entre les forces
russes et ukrainiennes et là évidemment
et bien les électriciens disent qu'ils
ne pourront pas rétablir le courant
avant l'été prochain le ministre
français des armées illustrat demain à
Kiev Sébastien Lecornu devrait donner
des réassurance au pouvoir ukrainien
oui tout à fait alors les Ukrainiens
sont évidemment extrêmement
reconnaissants pour toute l'aide qu'elle
soit militaire humanitaires financière
qu'ils peuvent recevoir de la communauté
internationale c'est grâce à cette aide
qu'ils peuvent résister qu'ils peuvent
repousser l'invasion russe ils ont une
zone sur un sentiment un petit peu
ambigu vis-à-vis vis-à-vis de la France
puisque d'un côté la France aide
militairement affirme aussi son soutien
à l'Ukraine puisqu'elle a déjà livré 18
annonces César elle s'apprête à en
livrer 6 à 12 autres prix au Danemark à
des missiles des lances des
lance-roquettes des missiles crottaques
aussi courtes portées donc pour ceci les
Ukrainiens sont extrêmement
reconnaissants mais d'un autre côté ils
ont un petit peu le sentiment que les
Français aident d'une main et voudraient
peut-être éduquer de l'autre puisque ces
propos d'Emmanuel Macron sur le fait
qu'il ne fallait pas humilier Vladimir
Poutine qu'on ne qu'il ne pouvait pas ne
pas dialoguer avec un tel président que
lui et bien ses propos ici en Ukraine
ils passent très mal les Ukrainiens
redoutent un peu que la France serait
prête à pousser les Ukrainiens à
dénégociations avec la Russie malgré le
fait qu'aujourd'hui les Ukrainiens
veulent récupérer la totalité de leur
territoire ne sont prêts à aucun
compromis sur le donbasse et la Crimée
donc le sentiment vis-à-vis de la France
est un petit peu plus ambiguë que
vis-à-vis ont des États-Unis qui eux
expriment davantage une aide
inconditionnelle à l'Ukraine et qui
livre aussi des missiles plus lourds et
plus longues portées plus performant
comme c'est patriote qui ont été promis
il y a tout récemment par Joe Biden
Apollo diverselenski lors de sa visite à
Washington merci Helena Volochine avec
nous en direct de qui a